okay this is our first movie review
terrain my new series right here and
it's the thing John Carpenter's The
Thing yeah we picked this movie to do
first I mean specifically because it's
kind of well it's one of my favorite
memories one of your favorite horror
maybe you have not of everyone if you
have not seen this movie get the [ __ ]
out of here
right now I don't wait for real if you
haven't seen this movie you can see it
on YouTube for about private $2.99 watch
this movie now and then come back I'm
gonna say about by one of the greatest
movies of all times
all right iwase well that's kind of
reaching in it well is a little
hyperbolic yeah yeah one of the probably
the best horror sci-fi horror movies
yeah I would I would say that it's
definitely one of the best horror
especially a low-budget one yeah never
believed that this was basically a
low-budget movie it doesn't look like
and it does not feel like it and it's
funny too because when it came out at
the time it came out of 1982 it didn't
do all that well like it didn't flop
exactly no but it didn't do as well as
they wanted it you I had to go ahead to
head with ett and he and Blade Runner
came out the same day right so et has
been out for a couple week at that point
and et of course was like a huge
juggernaut every good I thought when I
was 10 everyone thought the same yeah
and then there was the Hawaiian release
the King haha he's teasing me because
every time I type it I forget to put a
kid in there so I keep going is it a boy
versus an alright not the Tingler that's
a total joke right brought us through it
this was 1982 1982 John Burroughs
directed by John Carpenter director of
many a great many good horror films and
some not so great well what was one of
the things that I thought was great
about this movie is that it's taken
place on the South Pole and it's all men
as like a weather station it was or it
was a better research they took on
research they yeah and they find a
basically an alien alien in a block of
ice too
there's more to it than that but they
find an alien in a block of ice and it
gets out and this alien organism has the
ability to take over a human body kind
of like a virus and reprogram itself and
it could make itself into a copy of
whatever it takes over and also it has
the memory of all the other things that
it took over in the past so it's a
monster that can look like you or look
like anything that it looked like in the
past and a mixture of all that [ __ ]
together which is really a great concept
I mean you can't really think of much
scarier than that I mean the thing it
was actually based on a short story or a
novella rather called who goes there and
it was made into a movie in 1951 called
the thing from another world but that
was it
I don't think it was as close to the
book I haven't read the book since I was
a kid so I don't really remember much
about it I don't think I ever wrote but
um but I think john carpenter's version
is a little bit closer to the original
to your original thing and it seems to
me like especially the 60-70 daisy up
80s a lot of horror movies were kind of
concerned with people like their
greatest fear being losing their
identity or not knowing you know like
invasion of the Body Snatchers I thought
remain on inside communism yeah it could
be read in that way but I think that's
also kind of one of humans most primal
fears is that you know there's a monster
but it also looks just like your dad or
your wife or something and you have no I
acts just like them kind I always
thought that it was an analogy for
communist subversion although with the
thing I was you know young enough under
my dad taking me to see this thing you
know in 82 it would have been about what
14 15 something like that
heard my dad taking me maybe a little
bit younger under my dad take me to see
this thing it was a startling movie in
his day yeah I really didn't had no idea
what was coming it was just very ominous
in the end the theater went berserk
under the influence of this day the
thing yeah it was it was a different
time
it was weird and what I kind of felt
from it I thought the thing was kind of
an analogy for aids that's what I
remember because there was kind of an
AIDS epidemic I believe going on at that
time
well yeah although I think well really I
mean virus you know yeah that was the
analogy I was a connection all the cool
thing about this movie and I think why
it's kind of resonated with people
throughout generations and why this kind
of story you know resonates through with
old people young people everything same
with invasion of the body snatchers is
that you can really apply it to so many
different things and say you know ply it
to like you know kind of communist
regime like everyone has to be the same
now or or it can be like a virus or the
original story I think the original
story was about communist subversion
right that's what it was about but I
remember it making me making kind of a
connection with AIDS yeah a virus but
myth is except I was young and they've
always talked about viruses and AIDS
virus and when they showed the doctor
you know when what was his name Blair
Blair trying to figure it out over the
microscope and they showed it
intersecting kind of a virus so today I
made the connection of a virus yeah yeah
I can see how that when they go over the
whole world because remember what a
second we were kid we thought we were
told that aids was going to infect the
entire world yeah it was like a big deal
back then and I mean 82 that was kind of
like that was kind of the beginning of
it we first started hearing about it
yeah pandemics yeah taking over the way
that's what I kind of thought that they
were talking about yeah but honestly I
think the thing I've always liked about
this movie is that they did such a good
job with like isolating everyone and
there's really nothing scarier than
being isolated in a place you can't get
out of I mean they're in the middle of
the South Pole yeah you know they're
then their helicopter crashed and and so
they're kind of stuck there I'll copy
got destroyed yeah yeah that's right and
they have no idea who has been taken
over so then they start turning on each
other because any one of them or all of
them could be the alien this is the only
movie that I can think of that has an
all-male cast and there's something
about that too then this all men yeah
and they all start turning on one
another not trusting each other yeah
remember when and I'll tell you what my
boys in this of course you know Russell
let's go Russell I think the Kurt sounds
better
so the Kurt okay like the half and the
shot is shat in the Kurt yeah he's cool
you know I really liked him in that
skate from New York - what's funny - he
was a Mouseketeer yeah totally just be
kind of came a heavy welcome a little
heavy because now he's doing movies with
yeah you know well it's just he's kind
of a badass if you see is you know yeah
it doesn't play the Hollywood game he's
kind of like a regular guy you know he
likes trucks and guns and [ __ ] like that
it's interesting too because really
before he was in the thing before he was
in Escape from New York and stuff like
that he was mostly in like Disney yeah
how many and yeah he was uh yeah I'm out
of here so you know we were watching the
thing about them escape from New York
the other day and John Carpenter pretty
much insisted that Kurt Russell be in
that and he didn't want to do it if that
really made it and we get it did but we
got to see how to stay on the thing
though yes escape from the ort where
that we're going to do that on and that
separately that that's a fantastic film
- but well it's funny because you were
saying about the the all-male cast and
stuff like that now they did do sort of
a well it was kind of a reboot and kind
of a prequel in 2011 yeah it was also
called bay bay it was the prequel kind
of the prequel yet because it goes only
what happens to the Norwegian group that
originally on this alien because they
did find what was left of that group in
right movie yeah so they had to go back
but that had females in that cast just
one I think that what people - one or
Taylor but I'm not gonna [ __ ] on that
movie because I actually really like I
like that one - I thought that was
really good yeah it did a good job but
there was something about the thing the
alienation the ice of the feeling of
isolation it's nothing but guys there
had a very gritty realistic feel for in
1982 it would have been just men there
yeah that's just the way the society was
the the rivalry between the guys under
stress you know the thought was very you
know accurate there's an aisle speech
yeah Nyles wanted to take over
Oh Niles we need through a little bit of
a cooler head you know it was famous
cool - cool flick I don't know should we
give spoilers on this er I'm sure
everyone this way everybody it's an old
movie you know and really okay and I
should just say right out of the gate
every single one of these reviews is
going to have spoilers yeah anyway so
we're just like shooting the [ __ ] about
the movie and it's like we spoil it
sorry but I'm warning you right now
every single I was gonna I remember when
I was in the theater and I was a kid and
that guy that guy who had the heart
attack and it gave him the damn
resuscitation with it what would he call
the damn shock banquet he call it yeah
there's all that because everything
today - the different distinctive really
narrator is a prim proper Brady he hit
that dude that defibrillator in the dam
and then his chest opened up and bit his
arm down and the entire audience was
just like what oh you know you get her
women screaming in the background and
then then when they hit it with the
flamethrower and that head fell off and
sprouted legs the entire audience was
going is [ __ ] well because no one had
ever known that in a mishap CGI back
then that was all done with practical
effects and it still looks great yeah
and the thing is when you've watched
horror movies in that era you weren't
sure what state-of-the-art technology
was yeah you weren't sure one Lookadoo
I'm not sure what they could show you
right well after that movie man I was
[ __ ] up I was like oh [ __ ] it can only
get worse about it was it was traumatic
well you guys like that you do not know
I had no idea you know I had already
seen aliens by that time I mean that was
pretty gory yeah I took alien is just
read reality yeah I was young when I saw
alien my my dad didn't see that way
it's like Kevin wants me to comment you
know some British guy said you know your
parents let you watch The Shining at
eight nine oh yeah
yeah it was on TV mind until in United
States that [ __ ] was on TV yeah I said I
give you another family the British were
real hard on the younger generation Q
but like no man can be I don't know
seriously when I was growing up I mean
my parents I've got into horror when I
was really little mostly mostly reading
it at first but then I got
you know movies and stuff like that they
used to take me to the old video store
and let me rice all kind for My Bloody
Valentine all this last shirt if you ask
me you should take your boys to see
horror movies yeah because it's kind of
educating eyes on it yes there is danger
they took me to me they took me to the
theater to see phantasm yeah because I
really want to see it um they took me to
see nightmare Elm Street there's all
that stuff and I wasn't that old I mean
you know I was just maybe 10 yes well we
don't really have to be super precise
with these reviews I mean this is the
first one that we've done so far for our
channel because these things have been
so extensively reviewed by other yeah
but I mean it's like if you want to know
like all the technical stuff but you
know what I was going to say that was it
when I was forgot all about it
the practical effect thing about about
all of the thing you know where he puts
the his arms and the saying yeah my I
saw mrs. I was like do you know how the
how they did that that guy really didn't
have any arms yeah lost his arms and
they pick that guy specifically they
were like that yeah it didn't have arm
and the arms that got got bitten were
made of jello and wax yellow with wax
boned which I feel like I don't do that
much anymore they don't really utilize
people that have disabilities and stuff
like that
jeans were dedicated back in I feel like
that's a good idea well they were craft
made these movies were craft made yeah
yeah they were they were really into it
I really had guy who shot it back in
those days who did that those special
effects says he prolly wouldn't attempt
that again said that it was just lucky
to come out as good as it did well over
some times they tried it before and it
fail yeah I'll call fire yeah I remember
when they hit with a flamethrower that
fire almost got out of control but I'm
not on that take on the tank before
right well that's the thing it kind of
seems like doing all those practical
effects and stuff like that because now
it's so easy to select slapped with CGI
whatever I mean like I said what was
that stupid preview or watching though
that it wasn't even sharknado it was
like shark avalanche or three-headed
shark or something like that and it was
just like no it was no it was yeah it
was it was shark avalanche
all right so shark Avalanche and there's
a [ __ ] fin coming out of the mountain
or something like that it's just you can
CGI anything yeah you can see GI so
hedid charge they look like [ __ ] you
know it's not there but you know it's
not there it doesn't have any weight it
doesn't look that good either really
good CGI still doesn't look that great
tonight it's only good for backgrounds
and yeah it's good if you sparingly or
like to kind of enhance with already
there s CG best CG I've seen was in a
fury road because they were just trying
to yeah agent is that super enhancement
yeah they're a racing tire track they
didn't use it to create whole characters
or anything like that which to me it
just never works it never looks right
you know is another good thing about the
thing is the ambiguous ending and okay
now actually there was supposed to be
there is an Eastern scene at the end
where he tests his blood and he's still
human oh yes but they took that out but
they took it out because John Carpenter
thought it works better right because it
was just it was damping it left you just
with his really ominous feeling of dread
yeah you don't know well because and I
always really liked any outbreak wasn't
technically contained no because they'd
be frozen and people would eventually
come there yeah to see what had happened
to the expedition or to the to the
member booth
we call it dancing it's a lab station
yeah
never seen why they'd lost contact of it
and they would have been read yet and
what it said I would have gotten out
there to send people there and the thing
is if you didn't know what was going on
at their time and you just like wandered
in there I've got taken over and then
went back there where they were taking
the bodies back to the United States and
was thought out right yeah so that was
another scary thing about it is that
really there would be if that really
happened and realized there would be no
way to contain that no way whatsoever
no cuz David had done an investigation
and picked up all those frozen yeah
burned up bodies and had taken them back
and they would they would have breathes
because why would you even think of that
you would not think of an alien would
come here and take over and make like a
super Agua copy how could you help I
remember when I was sitting in the
theater and saw the opening scene of the
flying saucer I got some bad [ __ ] here
bad [ __ ] here and then it cuts two guys
chasing a dog
guys in a helicopter chasing a dog
shooting at the dog yeah
I'm immediately go man who is this
[ __ ] shoot it and I know exactly
that's not Darwin involving a [ __ ] damn
and they tell the dudes for shooting the
dog I was crazy so they're just big
wasn't the dog you know and it was just
it's really one of the best movie
openings better just begin just the way
it kind of like manipulates your
expectations like that it was genius
you're amazing a dead dog this house I
touch I know right because ever and he
knows everybody knows you don't [ __ ]
with a dog do you know B you can kill
all the people you want yeah don't
[ __ ] dog and in my case don't [ __ ]
with a cat don't kill a cat and move
around like you can kill all DP you can
kill kids I don't give a [ __ ]
in Italian movies they did kill kids
they did yeah if you kids up like a well
the Italians I don't know what it is
about the detective but and I love
Italian harmoo I'm a huge like Dario
Argento fan of a huge Lucio Fulci fan
I'll probably do some of their movies at
some point on the show but they were
just they were just over the top with
the gore yeah and killing kids they gave
no [ __ ] no not at all it's like here if
it seems like a lot of movies kind of
pull their punches on that yeah now the
movie we saw in the movie the other day
a clown yeah oh yeah they killed a bunch
of kids in that now I'd like a gue you
guys could not officially don't do that
but the fat kids fingers off yeah that's
right that's right so I kind of like I
respect movies that kind of have the
stones to do that could actually I'll
kill a kid I'll tell you what if you
didn't see the thing in the theater back
in 1982 with a 1982 audience along with
you okay and you're a kid yeah though
you don't know what you were missing
yeah oh man that movie was that was a
life-changing event well really was
yeah because I was used to caught the
best special effects I had seen was
alien one up to that point that was that
was that movie changing alright I was a
god damn alien one seemed like reality
well so did this and they showed a lot
more weird [ __ ] in the thing than they
did alien Liang was weird but they
didn't show fool
informations and people getting absorbed
and blacks live a red slime run across
floors and come as bizarre and it was
just uh and it kind of had that same
feeling of alienation and isolation that
alien one had in space you're on the
South Pole yeah this anything like it's
just somewhere where you're crapping you
can't get out and you can't contact the
outside world and then a lot of it was
happening during a storm and yet
couldn't walk from one building to the
next without a rope you get lost you
could never be there yeah because you
visibility was so low you'd get lost and
you know me being in Korea in those
Korean winters 50 degrees below zero I
know exactly what they're talking about
yeah yeah so I didn't man but I don't
know yeah by the thing well the thing to
and I kind of feel even though it's kind
of sucks being as old as I am but I'm
not dead but you know I don't think kids
today how much fun we did
well that's I was going to say in a lot
of ways I think that's why a lot of
younger like kind of a lot of younger
filmmakers and stuff like that are going
back to like the seventies and eighties
movies and stuff like that I feel like
you know people our age we're really
lucky that are kind of formative years
yeah we're right at the beginning like
the home video good the home video boom
like MTV when it was good like all the
post-punk and all that music and stuff
like that it was like a huge explosion
of like really cool [ __ ] right around
the time that they were just coming into
being and there was something good about
pre-internet yeah could you weren't
being overexposed by things you know I
mean that you were limited yeah you know
and there was something about that
limitation it kind of gave us soon how
romance and adventure yeah sure what was
out there right away and just nowadays a
kick you get on the internet and see all
them you can find anything all very much
back when when back when we were kids go
to the movies was like a damn event and
everybody was there with you you go
today and is dead yeah nobody gonna
you're going to this is like a huge
event to see this movie it's only been
out for a couple of days you're not
really sure what's possible with
technology so you know you're almost
kind of like you know something from
third world country when you look at it
we were kind of third world with a
certain way back then but it
standards yeah yeah what country doesn't
have internet today North Korea you know
we were kind of innocent in a certain
way you know he didn't have think of how
hard was to find information back then
well you're not heartless yeah or if you
saw product if somebody had that product
you didn't know where they bought it you
couldn't get it yeah you know maybe that
came from New York
you know I know down the middle networks
right anyway you go and you this movie
was like an event it was like something
that's really happening to you
especially when you were young but I'm
doesn't seem to be that way anymore
though it seems like younger people are
totally immune to imagery you can show
anything they're just like yeah okay
well they've seen everything seen
everything I mean back in the old days
like I sent him some second the old
ittle bit I really didn't want horses
and buggies ha ha ha
we're broke dinosaurs you're gonna break
off yeah it's like the Flintstones
it was just like that game you're we
eating Mastodon that's right thank you
but yeah like back then we ran our
dinosaur to the video store and really
units like nowadays you hear about like
a cult movie that came out like it's you
know it's from Japan or like it's really
obscure nowadays it's pretty easy to see
it's somebody selling it on eBay or
something like that back in the old days
you kind of heard about it like through
the grapevine yeah you it was hard to
find it was kind of a big deal like and
you'd probably get like a pirated VHS of
it from some other country or something
you weren't sure how many record albums
were out there the ban do you like if
you weren't sure how many Bauhaus albums
there were yeah because there were
different European releases yeah
whatever now and then you'd be in some
like little dinky a letter and find one
year like that sounds like all kind of
weird bootleggers if there's a VHS tape
oh wow Sheils where'd you get that I had
that yeah I ordered have it I ordered it
from burning Airlines in New Jersey I
wonder if that's still around I used to
get all my shirts on VHS from them so
anything else about the thing probably
not okay Whedon wrapping up this is the
very first one you know our first
episode was kind of a movie review on it
well it was kind of about the shining
and also about the entity but it was
kind of about the real case a real about
identity and then we talked about the
shining but we talked about all those
dumb conspiracy theories about look you
guys liked our
movie review experience I guess you
could call it like a movie retrospective
it's a movie experience you have movie
retrospective we did we retrospectively
looked at the thing if you like this
will do more yeah I think I think
actually people will like these yeah I
feel like we're gonna have fun doing
this yeah this is yeah
alright so hope you guys yeah I got some
good ones on a list I'm gonna do slash
[ __ ] Gordon oh my god I can't wait to
do that actual undertones undercurrent
and Flash Gordon man were intense when
you were looking 1314 man come on man
you'll still need to dress up as him for
Halloween addresses Ming what I want to
dress as colitis oh that's right yeah
come on it yet okay
never get we're going to do that when
you're with main radar what was her name
the the what was a princess or I can't
remember yeah some Romanian girls yes
thank you for waiting anyway yeah okay
yeah we'll get to that
okay so hope you guys enjoyed this first
installment of our new movie review show
see you later
and don't forget our patreon we're
always in Brubaker's thank you